what's going on guys this is Rob and I
feel like this mic is in a weird
location is in a weird spot there we go
what's going on guys this is Rob ignore
the mess back there I am in the middle
of cleaning everything up that's Max's
dog hair it's all over the place
oh my god max max you shed where are you
at max there he is
there's max right there max you shed
like a madman you should be ashamed of
yourself a shitty not bad
yes you shed and you're so lovable
anyway guys those are you guys you don't
know a couple things you I I miss doing
these little vlog things so you know
what I think I'm gonna do I think I'm
gonna bring back comics to coffee but do
it like once a month because doing it
every week kind of burn me out just
because you know because I was doing it
so frequently people just didn't really
have new questions to ask and so a lot
of times the conversation would just
boil down to like Batman versus Black
Panther who do you think wins and and
that's you know it's it's interesting to
do versus series which I think that's a
good idea to do like versus series can
find a comic books that way I'm not
stepping on you know the territory of
that what's the name of that channel
that does like the vs. series the super
battles or whatever it is I can't what
it's called epic battles or I keep being
epic Rap Battles I don't know anyway um
as you guys know I'm very Spacey so I
think I'll do comics and coffee like
once a month
it'll be like every you know once every
Sunday like the first Sunday of every
month or something like that with the
exception of October because I won't be
there so maybe it'll be the last Sunday
every month I don't know anyway that
brings me to my to my next point so
after two and a half minutes of rambling
nonsensically for however long I have
written a book I wrote a book yes behind
the Cape like this is so this book runs
over the history of Superman and I don't
know how many of you guys know much
about you know a lot about Superman I
imagine that that when it comes to
Superman is a character because his
history is so expansive people know
things here and there you know like they
know you know about Silver Age Superman
being wildly powerful you know they know
Superman first appeared in Action Comics
issue number one he's created by Siegel
and Shuster things like that well this
book that I wrote
gives you the whole the whole rigmarole
for example I hear here's like one of
the chapters is one of the chapters
deals with the okay like the near
collapse of the comic book industry one
of the things a lot of people don't know
is the death of Superman story almost
collapsed the comic book industry
because of variant covers and because of
you know it was super high selling
things like that it talks about the
fallout of the death of Superman how did
that affect the coming of a community
you know how it basically destroyed his
comics for a decade you know and it's
only really been recently that it's
comics too started to take back off
again because Superman rebirth is
amazing oh my god it's so good but this
deals with like the legal issues you
know the lawsuits for over Superman you
know that stretch since the 1940s all
the way out like basically at the entire
life of Siegel and Shuster in the realm
of comics it deals with their families
even after you know that after the
passing of Shuster I think it was um it
deals with you know the the actually
sequel to you know it deals with you
know although all the lawsuits and
everything you know it deals with the
Superboy's creation you know it talks
about what led up to the creation of
Superman in the first place so if you
guys really dig like the whole explained
concept I think you guys will you know
will love this but it would be a link to
it down in the description um you know
it'll be and it'll be at Barnes and
noble.com do you guys can check it out
but because of the fact that myself and
and the weekly pool because we're going
to be at New York comic-con if you guys
get this then bring it to New York Comic
Con because we're going to be doing both
assigning because we're gonna have a
panel and we're also going to we're also
going to have a fan meet up there we go
we're gonna have a fan meet up for those
of you guys who were not able to get
tickets to New York comic-con because of
those you guys who don't know New York
comic-con is is like the weekly poll
comic-con not to say that it that it
it's based on us it's not is to say that
it's like the one comic-con that we all
try to make it to now I couldn't go last
year just because of the fact that I was
at a wedding I was at a friend's wedding
and I couldn't miss that the beautiful
Dan and Sarah got married and it was a
it was an awesome experience we went to
a distillery
we had whiskey actually we had bourbon
but it was it was a really great
experience but as you guys
I'm really excited um cleaning for
whatever reason just gets me excited I
know some people are just like it's your
problem but uh but yeah anyway so um so
yeah you know we know that some of you
guys couldn't get tickets to New York
Comic Con but some of you guys look
around the New York New Jersey Baltimore
you know Virginia area and a lot of the
guys want to meet us and so we're gonna
be doing a fan meetup I'm pretty sure
and of course you know that whoa well
you know follow us on social media
follow me on comics explained follow
Benny on comics torreón follow salad
coming pop follow follow Caitlyn you
know follow us on Twitter and and even
like the weekly poll has its own Twitter
account make sure you follow that as
well and you guys will know where we're
at in the con so if you guys get into
the you know getting to come New York
comic-con
if you guys don't happen to run into us
you know will occasionally be tweeting
out where we're at or we'll be tweeting
out when our panel is so you guys can
come in and listen to us do a live
weekly pull episode but yeah you know
you know it'd be awesome you know to see
you guys out there so again for those of
you guys who couldn't make it out to the
con who couldn't get tickets we're gonna
be doing a fan meetup and if you guys
bring books both Vinny and myself will
sign our books cuz bidding has a book
too many wrote a book as well about the
history of comic book movies I'm pretty
sure and it's actually really cool like
it's a really cool book so so make sure
you guys you know get our books bring
them there we'll sign them for you you
know and you guys can go home and be
like Rob but uh but anyway guys yeah
it's shameless shameless promotion of my
book I know but I'm really excited
because I'll be honest guys um it's it's
you know and I'm sorry to get mushy
here you know I'm sorry to get mushy on
this because I know that some of the
guys are just like mushy stuff
yuck which by the way this is a
coca-cola thing
no coca-cola did not pay me to say this
but there was a coca-cola store in
Disney World and I saw this and I had to
get it this is water because coca-cola
is not good for you that's how you know
that I'm not advertising coca-cola I'm
telling you that it's bad for you so do
not be like Rob yours
sellout which is something that I really
hope you guys put the comment section I
shouldn't say that but but when I
started this whole thing when I started
comments explaining the channels had its
ups and downs there's been times where
I've been trying to figure out the
channels direction there were times when
I got really burned out of doing 20
minute long videos I try to convince
them down I was trying to adjust the
channel to how YouTube's algorithm
worked there was it was it's it's been
like a huge insane learning curve and
you know there's there's been fans that
have just bailed out and they'll never
come back that's okay you know it's the
it's it's really just a learning process
and along the way I've had so many
awesome experiences the most notable is
you it's like interacting with you guys
there is actually hold on it's like let
me go and grab it real quick
I know you're not supposed to do this
but let me go let me go see if I can
find it real quick cuz I want to [ __ ] I
want to show you guys
just sit around and sleep all day long
okay I know you're never supposed to
leave in the middle of a YouTube video
but I did it this is my most prized
possession this not because it's a force
a force is a really cool comic whatever
it's because this represents the first
meetup that I ever did with yes myself
and Benny went to San Antonio Texas to
hang out with Drake and we made the
decision in the last minute because we
went to Six Flags we were like we should
do a fan meetup too so literally it was
whoever happened to be on Twitter during
that two-hour window knew we were gonna
be at a comic book store and something
like 20 people showed up and I had all
the people who showed up autograph this
these are your signatures these aren't
comfortable crazy these are your
signatures these are fans signatures you
know these are these are people that
that I had never met up until that point
but they found my channel on YouTube and
they loved it and this is this is so
cool like I love this so this is one of
the things that I love so much um you
know I need to put it back there is
wanting to do I need to take down the
first order thing which by the way look
at that it looks amazing it looks so
cool the first order thing I need to put
this in its place um that by the way is
the mask of Draco Malfoy from Harry
Potter Harry Potter fans unite I love
you guys um this video is all over the
place
if you've stuck with the video this far
congratulations thank you but um but
yeah you know it's it's I never I never
dreamed in a million years that it would
get to this point where people want to
meet me as a person even if they only
walk up and they just say hey like I
love the videos that you make which is
an incredible experience um I never
thought I would have an impact on
anybody's life like I never thought and
you know I real talk for a second I've
had experiences in my life where it's
its tummy that sometimes people are good
sometimes people are bad but I never saw
myself as a person that would do a thing
and have an impact on people's life like
a real and
in fact I never thought I would have
that and and I wouldn't go as far as to
say that I've somehow shaped the world
not at all I'm a guy that makes videos
about comic books but a lot of you guys
have found my channel and you love you
know my channel because maybe I
reintroduce you to comic books after you
took a hiatus for however many years
maybe it's because you know you were
looking to get into comic books for the
first time then you stumbled across
Civil War were you stumbled across you
know DC rebirth or something like that
actually I'm curious supposed to comment
down below and tell me how it is you
haven't haven't across my channel did
you find me through Benny do you find me
through comic pop did you just find me
through a Google search or youtube
search or like how do you find my
channel I'm curious um but you know it's
but you know being able to meet you guys
and hang out with you guys isn't is an
incredible experience and that's why we
love fan meetup so much that's why you
know I love them Benny loves them Sal
loves them because we get to hang out
with with you guys and talk to you guys
about stuff now granted nine times out
of ten when we meet you guys it's always
hey man I really love your videos and
it's like cool man I appreciate it and
then almost without fail who's your
favorite comic book character I love you
guys for that it's it's hilarious to me
you guys always ask that who's your
favorite comic book character of course
mine's the century um but you know
Superman is actually Superman I think is
one of the best comic book characters
but nonetheless um so yeah if you know
if if you made it this far in the video
you know that's that's cool again we're
gonna be a New York Comic Con coming out
I wrote a book they're behind the cape
you know you can find on Barnes Noble
the leak will be down in the description
if you if you end up getting it you know
if you if you decide to buy it and
you're gonna be at New York bring it and
I'll autograph it for you but yeah you
know it's it's you know it's it's it's a
cool experience guys you know it's it's
awesome being able to do this you know
and it's all because of the support you
guys show you know so yeah you know I'm
yeah this is gonna be three videos today
oddly enough it's gonna be this video
it's gonna be the two superman videos
and in this video this video I'm gonna
have loaded like 9 o'clock
night so you know I'm so I'm sorry if
I'm kind of burning you guys out the
good thing is I'm giving you Saturday
and Sunday to catch your breath so new
videos will be out on my decks but but
anyway yeah so I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap this up guys and I guess I will
catch you all later peace